hello guys I'm Ryan right
I'm Jerry have you seen this yet no okay
yeah I neither do i but it sounds fun
a lot of people sent this to me Star
Wars The Force awakens trailer budget
videos so that you could rave rave
[Music]
that's pretty good actually
yeah who are you
I know what kind of aggressive I was
raised to do one thing
but I've got nothing to fight for Beach
nothing will stand in their way
company
what you still that's pretty good
ah
there are stories that happened
it's true so creative
[Music]
the dark side the Jedi
they're real
[Music]
it's calling to you
[Music]
possible
[Music]
I love that very charming that was
awesome does that seem like other people
do those kind of videos before yeah they
always look like a blast to put together
but then all the time I'm like be so
time-consuming though you know yeah I
mean it would take time because they
still staged things they still got a lot
of people together like they still
probably made all those little crafts
and things exactly like that it look
like I don't know let's watch it it's
that I was like Star Wars I'm like they
know more it's not like talking about
Star Wars with his Jerry's I mean
judging by that little screenshot there
it almost looks like they're gonna do
recreate the trailer but oh really fun
like if you're in your backyard
recreating this oh I've always wanted to
do stuff like that well hey man you
could we're gonna collab if that's what
the surface you're on youtube you can do
anything I know I could look at other
people's Taunton and rave about it yeah
low bunch of version of Star Wars but
like it's gonna budget but it kind of
works so it takes time yeah exactly it's
like they're making they're making fun
at times and at times you're like that
kind of looks like cool artwork yeah it
straddles that weird middle line between
being kind of kooky but also like that's
pretty cool yeah it seems like they use
locations they use sets it wasn't just
like you know people filming in their
backyard or something it looks like a
video yeah they actually bought it feet
whoa ear is ringing and fabricate a few
things my rock concert know is I feel
like one of my ear cells died know
you'll never hear that frequency again
so they say I don't know if that's true
okay trainings over guys don't worry the
only parts I didn't like was when they
tried throwing in like their own random
jokes
yeah with r2d2 when his head falls off
yeah yeah I feel like that might have
been an outtake and they thought it was
funny yeah I like some of the random
bits like went with r2d2 and
even kind of the Han Solo joke at the
end yeah I think they could work in a
future video they just got to tighten up
the pace a little bit maybe yeah
although I like the one where they have
those jokes specifically not the resin
the joke they added I liked was when
Finn and your [ __ ] PO like there they
say they do that do that like turn
around yeah I tell you kept speaking
yeah yeah that was pretty funny like
that's a joke that started that that was
pretty good you know yeah yeah yeah
that's one that doesn't disrupt the flow
like the music doesn't stop you know it
just keeps going exactly funny but it
still keeps the thing go back instead of
pausing for it and as opposed to a lot
of the ones that I've seen before I like
the different emotions I was getting
from it where it would be like that's
kind of cool omage or they made that
work
yeah it's really funny that they're
making fun of that would you know like I
like them [ __ ] wrinkles whom the guy
is doing on so the stage makeup like
yeah you that's that's like the best way
to make fun of his age without having to
crack a joke yeah exactly like it's a
visual joke with ink I can still you
know deliver the lines series that's
that's the word visual jokes like I
don't often feel like we get just really
good visual jokes these days yeah a good
a good gag that doesn't inhibit a
performance can go a long way you know
it's like he could still deliver the
line but it's it's kooky that they've
done it yeah but that's what you would
have to do like you know in the guise of
low-budget like that's what you have to
do I highly recommend you guys watch the
original video if you guys haven't seen
it yes it's from the channel do you
named Matthew Potter he almost has 6,000
subs but damn is this guy deserved more
as long as he keeps it up you know as is
the way I feel with a lot of youtubers
he has clearly done almost the same
amount of work I do per video yeah
almost almost he's almost up there he's
is kind of trying you know I think you
need more jump cuts I think there's one
camera I think they're see a segment
where you guys are just watching the
Star Wars trailer yeah you know we're
like watching something maybe you don't
have to see what you're won all the
costume you lose the costume reduction
value
all the crap that doesn't matter you get
a couch from one camera one shot and
just talk and do it and I think that's
what you're looking listen guys if
you're new to the Chanel you can
subscribe today by becoming a reject
first you got to become a reject then
you can subscribe that's the way it
works
what yeah weird other people will be
like subscribed and your this thing no
not me nah me reasons to Jerry his movie
reviews and episodes that he guest stars
on my reaction really chef my clear is
mine it's mine when the president does
it Jay gasps dubs podcast hosted by
Jerry what's it about
no one really knows but they always end
up talking about something
I want to do a shout out to a guide and
Ethan Troy listen he said hey Ryan I
comment on heaps of your vids and like
all your vids I would be stoked I
thought I said I thought would be
stroked which would be more likely to
happen if you did get a shout out maybe
I got it by the way I love your vids
you're amazing and keep it up
Ethan Troy I am amazing and I will keep
it up you know Ethan Troy keeping it up
is one of the most important things you
can do honestly yeah Veronica and I
lately have been like struggling to get
an erection because it's been I I feel
nervous I feel pressure because she's so
hot and then so on that I was sometimes
it just dawns on me like I love this
woman and she's so hot that I have a
hard time keeping it up cuz I'm feeling
so much for my heart and not with my
penis yeah my heart is beating so fast
that there's just not enough blood
supply the both I am serious that's what
ends up happening I was introduced to
sex the really hardcore graphic
pornography okay you know yeah so I
never associated as like a love thing
okay so now I'm like no I have learned
it no I think you had to not you have to
yeah I know you know it now you're very
passionate man Ethan Troy these are the
reasons why you must learn to keep it up
because after I got past that little
struggle we have been boning like
nobody's business
is Ethan Troy actually from Australia I
don't care I'm just trying to talk about
my awesome sex with Veronica that I've
been having okay baby thank you for
enlightening me we have awesome sex that
way